en química nos encontraremos con muchas
situaciones en las que una molécula es
neutra pero debido a las diferencias de
electro negatividad y a la estructura de
las moléculas tal vez tenga una carga
parcial positiva de un lado y una carga
parcial negativa del otro lado y bueno
el ejemplo más famoso de eso es una
molécula de agua aquí tenemos tres
moléculas de agua la parte blanca es el
átomo de oxígeno y estos son los dos
hidrógenos esta es la forma de las
moléculas de agua y a veces también
pueden encontrarlas con los pares de
electrones libres en el oxígeno del lado
opuesto a los hidrógenos entonces una
molécula de agua es completamente neutra
tenemos 10 protones y 10 electrones en
total pero aún siendo neutra como tiene
esta forma y el oxígeno es más electro
negativo una de las terminales de la
molécula tiene una carga más positiva y
la otra terminal tiene una carga más
negativa
pero solo para reforzar esto veamos la
tabla periódica sabemos que en general
entre más nos movemos hacia arriba y
hacia la derecha de la tabla periódica
aumenta la electro negatividad así que
el oxígeno es uno de los elementos más
electro negativos y claro es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno entonces en
esta molécula de agua los electrones y
el enlace covalente entre el hidrógeno y
el oxígeno pasarán más tiempo en el
oxígeno podemos dibujar algo como esto
pasarán más tiempo en el oxígeno porque
al oxígeno le gustan más los electrones
así que se forma una carga parcial
negativa en la molécula del lado opuesto
a donde se encuentran los hidrógenos y
se forma una carga parcial positiva en
cada lado en el que se encuentran los
hidrógenos entonces aquí tenemos una
separación de cargas positivas y
negativas adentro de una molécula y a
esto se le conoce como dipolo molecular
escribir la dipolo molecular y este es
un dipolo eléctrico en el que ocurre la
separación de cargas positivas y
negativas y en este caso mostramos el
dipolo molecular que podemos encontrar
en una molécula de agua pero no se vayan
a confundir con el dipolo magnético de
ese hablamos en otros vídeos ahora en
una molécula de agua el de polo es
permanente porque no cambia la electro
negatividad al oxígeno le gustan más los
electrones por naturaleza entonces aquí
tenemos vamos a escribirlo aquí tenemos
un dipolo permanente
permanente
y gracias a eso las moléculas de agua se
atraen entre ellas entonces en esta
molécula este lado es parcialmente
negativo y esta parte es parcialmente
positiva y esta parte también es
parcialmente positiva y todo eso lo
podemos representar con esta delta
minúscula
esto también es parcialmente positivo
parcial positivo y parcial negativo ok
entonces como las moléculas de agua
tienen dipolos permanentes puede ocurrir
la atracción los lados parcialmente
negativos serán atraídos a las partes
parcialmente positivas y estos son los
famosos puentes de hidrógeno esa es la
atracción que podemos ver en el h2o pero
no todos los tipo los moleculares tienen
que ser permanentes aquí tenemos un
dibujo de algunas moléculas de metano el
metano es
h 4 y podemos ver que el metano es una
molécula que tiene una geometría tetra
erika en la que los hidrógenos están
igualmente distribuidos porque se
encuentran lo más lejos posible unos de
otros y observen que la electro
negatividad del carbono y de los
hidrógenos son diferentes el carbono es
un poco más electro negativo pero como
están cerca y tienen esta simetría en
este tipo de moléculas no hay un dipolo
permanente pero tenemos que recordar que
estos electrones se mueven entre los
enlaces y los núcleos de los diferentes
átomos no se quedan en el mismo lugar
puede ser que en cualquier momento
tengamos más electrones de este lado de
la molécula así que temporalmente
tendremos una carga parcial negativa y
tal vez una carga parcial positiva por
aquí y lo mismo puede ocurrir en esta
molécula y en esta molécula solo que tal
vez los electrones se encuentran más
distribuidos desde
tenemos una carga parcial negativa aquí
y una carga parcial positiva por acá
entonces cuando en un momento en
particular solamente tenemos estos
dipolos aleatorios cuando tenemos esa
distribución de electrones solo por un
momento a eso se le conoce como dipolo
temporal
dipolo
y esos dipolos temporales pueden crear
estas fuerzas temporales entre las
moléculas como por ejemplo en otros
vídeos estudiamos las famosas fuerzas de
dispersión de london entonces en el
momento en el que este lado es
parcialmente negativo y este lado es
parcialmente positivo tal vez en ese
momento esta molécula tiene una carga
parcial negativa de este lado y una
carga parcial positiva de este así que
los electrones pasan más tiempo de este
lado y por lo tanto las moléculas son
atraídas entre ellas por lo que esto ya
no es solamente temporal sino que
también puede ser inducido entonces si
esto ocurre así es decir que tengamos
una carga parcial positiva de este lado
bueno los electrones en esta molécula
serán atraídos a esa carga y a eso se le
conoce como dipolo inducido así que
podemos tener dipolos inducidos
si tenemos una fuerza externa en el
ambiente como
por ejemplo si tenemos un campo
eléctrico podemos tener un dipolo
inducido entonces supongamos que tenemos
una molécula de h2o por aquí y digamos
que tenemos una molécula de metano
neutro y en esa molécula de metano los
electrones se están moviendo esta
molécula no tiene un dipolo permanente
pero conforme se acerca a esta molécula
de agua como la molécula de agua tiene
un dipolo permanente en el que tenemos
una carga positiva por aquí puede ser
que los electrones de la molécula de
metano se sientan atraídos a la carga
positiva entonces en este caso tomamos
algo que de otra manera sólo tiene
dipolos temporales pero como ahora sus
electrones son atraídos hacia algo o
incluso se pueden sentir repelidos por
algo así logramos un dipolo inducido y
los dipolos no solamente ocurren con
moléculas que tienen múltiples átomos
aunque puede ser que no tengamos dipolos
permanentes pero si podemos tener
los inducidos o temporales en un solo
átomo por ejemplo supongamos que tomamos
un átomo de árbol los gases nobles son
famosos porque no reaccionan entonces
supongamos que aquí tenemos un átomo de
argón esta es su nube electrónica y
supongamos que ese es su núcleo esta es
una gran simplificación y ahora imaginen
que en algún momento los electrones
simplemente se encuentran un poco más
distribuidos de este lado ahí se forma
un dipolo temporal aquí tenemos una
carga más negativa y aquí tenemos una
carga más positiva y claro si esto se
encuentra junto a algo con lo que pueda
interactuar podemos inducir esto y ya no
sería algo tan aleatorio sino algo
inducido por una molécula cercana que
tenga un dipolo permanente o incluso
puede ser inducido por un campo
magnético entonces la idea de que los
polos moleculares ya sean permanentes
inducidos o temporales es muy útil
porque explica muchas de las propia
desde las moléculas como por ejemplo sus
puntos de ebullición y sus puntos de
congelación y nos dice qué tan difícil
es que puedan encontrarse en estado
gaseoso a comparación del estado líquido
o del sólido veremos mucho de eso en
química